here in britain this week we're having
to come to terms with some hard truths
that if you take people that have led a
life of luxury and privilege and place
them into positions of power and
influence they might turn out to be
complete
come on now let's try to have a heart
because it's been a horrible week for
the british prime minister opposition
parties are now united in their call for
boris johnson to go and the grand old
duke of york buckingham palace has
announced that prince andrew is
returning his royal and military titles
to the queen
yes he's been sacked for a second time
by his mum meaning he can no longer call
himself his royal highness but you can
still call him
these two upstanding sometimes lying men
are not getting the respect they've come
to expect be honest could you stand up
in front of tv cameras in front of the
entire nation and come up with the
excuses these two have been coming up
with and keep a straight face
that kind of fortitude and delusion can
only come from a life of extreme wealth
and privilege bungling boris and hansi
yanzi have been told their entire life
that they're better than everyone else
is it their fault if they've come to
believe it the real question is this
which of the poor excuses that these two
poor excuses for public figures have
come up with is your favorite
mr speaker i want to apologize is it the
way boris explained his attendance at a
boozy gathering of several dozen people
in his own downing street back garden
who were invited by his own senior
official to come along and enjoy the
weather and bring their own bottle even
while the rest of us were locked down
because of covert i believed implicitly
that this was
a work event
so here's boris at another work event
to be honest if working in downing
street involves bringing a bottle that
would explain a lot
or do you prefer prince andrew's excuse
that he can't possibly have had sex with
trafficked then teenager virginia dufrey
because he doesn't remember meeting her
despite the fact that this photo exists
where he's clearly in it and clearly has
his arm around her waist it takes some
serious breeding too with a straight
face deny you're in a photo which you
are quite clearly in then again andrew's
other attempts to excuse his alleged
involvement with trafficked victims of
suicided pedo jeffrey epstein include
insisting he can't sweat or that he was
at a [ __ ] pizza restaurant unlike
borisov i've got a feeling andrew might
actually believe what he says i live in
a
in an institution so two key figures of
britain's establishment face an
uncertain future
and by uncertain i still mean the kind
of future which involves extreme wealth
and privilege prince andrew's attempts
to avoid legal action by virginia du
frey in new york have pretty much failed
at this point she is suing prince andrew
alleging she was trafficked to him for
sex on three occasions in 2001. dufrese
wants her a day in court apparently but
uh in the way only a queen's son can
randy andy has just sold off one of his
luxury villas in the manner of a man who
might be preparing a large payoff well
things just keep going from bad to worse
for prince andrew now the duke is
looking to offload a 32 million swiss
chalet
can you believe it to help pay his legal
bills for boris and whether he can keep
his job as prime minister well currently
he's the political version of this why
lee coyote running off a cliff and not
noticing
[Music]
me
but all this is not entirely their fault
as i'm sure both will tell you it's our
fault the british people because we
voted for boris and we keep paying for
andrew let's try and be kind to them
when they're both forced to live in
exile disgrace by which i mean boris
becomes a highly paid consultant to an
investment bank and prince andrew has to
live a quiet life in one of his mum's
castles by the way downing street has
just had to apologize to the queen
because they held a couple of parties on
the night before her husband was buried
last year
it's her i feel sorry for